[Music]
think about how you got to work this
morning or the last time you flew on an
airplane in both of these cases you used
a combustion engine or a mechanical
engine that provided thrust it turns out
about 85% of the electricity that people
use in the world is generated on the
same principle using devices called
steam turbines the general idea is that
you burn some fuel and you boil water
use the resulting steam to turn a giant
fan blade the problem is these fan
blades are incredibly large and
incredibly expensive they're usually
about the size of a building and they
cost a couple billion dollars to put in
they don't scale down well to say an
application where you want power in your
backpack or when you want to be
off-the-grid such as in a data center
for when the grid goes out or you lose
power from the central power plant our
vision is to make power generation using
fossil fuels a lot more efficient and
even a 1% increase in the efficiency of
power generation using fossil fuels will
equal the entire contribution from all
of the solar panels deployed across the
world so modern electron is taking
another look at power generation on a
mobile and distributed scale we're
leveraging technology that has been
developed in the semiconductor industry
by companies like Intel in the last 30
years to build compact scalable
efficient and high power density
generators that can be used at almost
any scale for almost any application so
you can deploy them at small scales for
backpacks households medium scales for
backup power for buildings or data
centers or at large scale for grid scale
distributed generation to someday
replace central power plants
[Music]